في فرنسا بتزامن مع جلسه للبرلمان الفرنسي
بشان التصويت على مذكرتين لحجب الثقه عن
الحكومه بهدف اسقاطها بسبب قرارها تمرير
مشروع تعديل نظام التقاعد تستعد النقابات
لموجه جديده من الاضرابات في محاوله للضغط
على الحكومه للتراجع عن قانونها المثير
للجدل حيث يستعد مراقبه حركه الملاحه
الجويه للبدء في اضراب لينضموا الى
المسيرات احتجاجا على سن التقاعد
القانونيه من 62 الى اربعه وستين عاما
هيئه الطيران المدني دعت الى الغاء 30% من
الرحلات الجويه في مطار اورلي بالاضافه
الى 20% من الرحلات من مطار مدينه مرسيليا
الواقع جنوب فرنسا الرئيس الفرنسي ايميل
ماكرون اعرب عن امله بان يسلك مشروع مساره
الديمقراطي حتى النهايه في خطوه اعتبرت
تحديا لرفض القانون